el beto finalmente llegó el presidente
de ecuador guillermo lasso hizo públicas
sus observaciones este martes a la ley
del aborto por violación mis decisiones
siempre se enmarcarán en los límites
definidos en mis funciones
constitucionales por eso he decidido
incluir observaciones al proyecto de ley
con el objetivo de que esté guarde
absoluta concordancia con el dictamen de
la corte constitucional el veto es
parcial e incluye 61 textos alternativos
y objeciones a los plazos para el acceso
la objeción de conciencia a los
requisitos entre otros artículos la
corte constitucional en respuesta a
varias demandas de inconstitucionalidad
interpuestas por colectivos de mujeres y
feministas del país despenalizó el
aborto en casos de violación en abril
del 2021 justo cuando las asumía la
presidencia el reto estaba en precedente
reconocida en la constitución sin
embargo el presidente ha violados
porque este es un punto claramente de
constitucionalidad y lo que establece la
misma constitución es que cuando en
armazones te motiva en el velo tiene que
ver con la constitucionalidad debe ser
enviado a la corte constitucional y no a
la zona uno de los puntos de
controversia es la reducción de los
plazos para el acceso a un aborto para
las niñas y mujeres de la ruralidad que
pasaría de 18 a 12 semanas un veto que
ha sido rechazado por los colectivos
feministas de ecuatorianos que han
venido por años trabajando por una ley
reparadora para las víctimas de abuso
sexual el presidente ni siquiera ha sido
capaz de escuchar la información de la
realidad de las mujeres en el país
el veto pone en riesgo a las más
vulnerables que son las mujeres y las
niñas que probablemente van a necesitar
un aborto en edades gestacionales por
sobre las 12 semanas en donde se
concentra la mortalidad y la morbilidad
de las mujeres que abortan entonces es
un veto que promueve la muerte enviado
el veto la asamblea tiene nuevamente en
sus manos la decisión de mantener el
texto original
en febrero o decidir si integra las
propuestas de lazo y para ello contará
con 30 días de plazo